what the this is amazing this is amazing
before we get started I just want to say
thank you so much for coming two hot
ones live this is like a dream come true
it's such a mindfuck to just look at
this so give yourselves a round of
applause holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] this is a dream come true
standing room only for hot ones but as
you can see I can't just eat wings by
myself up here what kind of show would
that be so let's make some noise for my
guest wale
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Wawa's released five full-length studio
albums two of which the album about
nothing in the gifted debuted at number
one on the Billboard albums chart but in
my opinion none of that means anything
if the guy can't handle his death sauce
male welcome to complex con welcome to
the show my man I'm very happy to be
here how are you with hot food or spicy
food guy
good but take my glasses off while I'm
eating it to indicate that I'm hot and
man's not hot yeah this is Valentina I
[Music]
eat like a [ __ ] sorry I I'll be eating
[ __ ] we'll be flying so from wale mania
to hosting Rap Battles on Smackdown to
publicly declaring that you want to
intern for Vince McMahon you've been
very much a part of the WWE fabric for
years and as someone with a foot in hip
hop and professional wrestling how
closely connected are those two worlds
in your opinion the more older I get the
more we see our hip-hop is really like
professional wrestling sports
entertainment like it's a couple like
real live people that's really acting
you know it's this is it's more theater
now that's as much as the the music go
you know how they present myself how
good they do they interviews I suck at
interviews well how could you do all of
these things those are the things that
matter in wrestling there's a lot of
parallels in this day and age especially
and then two years so close to the scene
have you ever come across a wrestler
that you think could make it in the rap
game and likewise a rapper that you
think could make it in WWE Ross the game
he burns like 450 pounds but I'm sure
them two good kids could last Rihanna
she could do everything
all right so this next one is crystal
you're not a crystal fan yeah just
tastes like hot sauce without the hot
sauce y'all know what crystals is right
yeah classic yeah but not for you no
tables no thanks to the mainstream
success from people like you and Kevin
Durant the DMV has been really lifted in
the pop lexicon but I still think that
people don't really understand the
culture of DC Maryland Virginia if
you're looking for the best food where
do you go in that region I think about
everybody trying to be more
health-conscious now you know so like
[ __ ] like the fresh food okay but I
mean I was a Carolina kitchen is like
probably my go-to now like they got like
four but if you want to party and meet
girls where do you go my DMS G I mean
you know any given night Saxby pop
Monroe's bar I shot to deejay money here
somewhere bliss if you really want that
real street vibe like be prepared
tactical gear that's pretty much it
though like these he's always been a
crab city though all right so this next
one is the secret aardvark it's not a
Portland I was like a real textbook bite
right there Oh mom
I've been rehearsing so these days there
seem to be so many celebrity
relationships that you can tell from the
outside looking in or phony as hell but
when it comes to your relationship with
Jerry Seinfeld it does seem to be rooted
in a shared admiration for each other's
grafts when you guys were working with
each other on the album about nothing
what was Jerry like in the studio is he
all pen and pad or was it just blunts
and lap dances with that guy yeah he
just goes and so he just sounds old like
well I could mine one time we something
Oh like pro wrestling and stuff like
that like so why do you watch this [ __ ]
oh man no you know I like what I like I
like some of this not like this away
from what I'm doing and he just starts
talking and he's like he like watches
like how like a construction boot is
created on YouTube like I'm like why do
you watch this [ __ ] like you know saying
like but then he'll get like
philosophical like on like just out of
nowhere his train of thought is crazy
but it's like so many relations with
that and their freestylers like people
who could go on the top of the dome but
his freestyle turned into like some
profound [ __ ] and if we talk about how
[ __ ] boot is made and I'm like yo did
you record that like a mess and
engineers this [ __ ] record it like this
[ __ ] like this with it if Jerry
ran out of comedians and he started
inviting rappers to get coffee with him
what kind of car do you think he'd pick
you up and so you asking me what kind of
car like defines me for it I'm kind of
saying if I want to get into the
psychology of it I'm kind of thinking
like what does Jerry think about male
according to while a if you wanted to
pull the curtain back I'll be the first
[ __ ] you pick up all right you
ready move on yeah all right so this one
is the Queen majesty it's the scotch
bonnet and ginger sauce no I'm a little
dry all right that's not there there's
logistical complications it's not easy
to do this just a little dry I'm gonna
saying like I'm not I don't know
somebody put a time effort in it I don't
mean it like that I'm saying that's why
I'm drinking water more water because
the chicken is just like I will keep
saying because it look like I'm trying
to sort the chef but is to maybe like I
don't know a dragon that g-pen might
have something to do I tell all my
surgeon Anika's back start a new ocean
so earlier this summer you deleted your
Twitter and Instagram explaining that
you need to make changes and find
happiness is going cold turkey on social
media as liberating as everyone says
there's fines [ __ ] you get into your
groove of like oh yeah there is
something out there like we do like
let's see what people are talking about
I just was doing up stuff like feel me
like I was just doing other things and I
had like 10 fake accounts trolling
everybody really know y'all believe that
no mom to say like it's just you know
you got time to focus on other things
like a lot of self-sabotage man late
nights how did I say that right and have
those little more well if you're not
scrolling anymore what are you filling
your time with Mario Brothers okay okay
that's NES mini [ __ ] Odyssey is just
[ __ ] fun right did you save the
tweets anywhere are they gone forever
like the lost works of Shakespeare it's
some application that somebody if I
don't use it no more man's over there
use thanks for shout out man's over
there you know who you are social media
people that's that's the new vibe to
have some time I do it for you and meet
real people in real life like y'all I
hope to meet some of you guys after this
no that [ __ ] took too long we're
supposed to do this [ __ ] my replacement
Chris Schaumburg he's from DC's like we
have a wallet yeah alright so this next
one is the hot one sauce you're on the
hot ones show not trying to lead the
witness so this is the one I'm gonna be
like this is the best sauce ever
you know five eats up all day you can be
honest with me be honest with me on this
one
no no but thank you good chick nah I'm
not going to say can't put that on me
alright while I so every Korean segment
on our show called explain that grin but
as we just covered you deleted your
Instagram which really throws a wrench
however mr. research if you Kylie check
chapter 0.1 1 2 / - instagram.com
backslash wale you will see that I have
7 oh okay well let me say this I knew
that you have seven posts on your entry
including only one that was from 3 2013
so don't have got it dive in that I was
just like what the [ __ ] am I doing this
all day long
don't come at me like that don't come at
me like that but anyway what I will say
is this homeboy comes through with the
sauce
homeboys homeboys gonna like get it but
we did discover a workaround what we've
done is we've sourced some of our
favorite pictures of wale with
professional athletes so what I'll do is
I'll show you the picture on these
monitors for the people out here in the
crowd they're gonna show up as they
already do over here and first things
first we have you and Kevin Durant at
Kevin Durant looking at each other which
is like man let's just get worried you
know you can you can help with both of
our birthday party well listen to this
so we had Kevin Durant on the show and I
was asking him about this but he was
basically like so blackout they doesn't
remember anything so now that I have you
here what do you remember about this and
I was like that was the last time I saw
that jacket I know that I lost it over
that oh I'm like damn shortest [ __ ] I'm
definitely thinking that I remember
jay-z and Drake came to that joint I'm
like I'm like the most 7th famous person
on my own [ __ ] that was pretty [ __ ] up
all right up next we have Winter Classic
Julianne Hough I love the ensemble here
what do you remember about this day
that's one of the great winners classic
the haberdashery is through the roof
it's off the scale I'm like a plaid
stars rainbows dots everything at the
same time that's you a supreme you know
that means something now that's [ __ ]
oh gee supreme [ __ ] like that's super
hight beast and I'm trying to show off
my ring and I think we lost that game to
the Penguins are you wearing the
Redskins piece and this I mean under got
it I always wear my brass kimchi's
suffered today it didn't work I know I
noticed I noticed it's beautiful
some happened to me after they defeated
all right next pick we have male with
fellow DC icon Vernon Davis who is also
in the sabotage video hmm if I have my
[ __ ] right yeah this is great research
if more people did their research like
you I promise you I wouldn't you
wouldn't be I wouldn't have any many
these outbursts would be like far a few
between
sure I appreciate that I haven't had one
in a long time though yeah you've been
pretty chill overdue
complex con get security ready all right
next up GQ Man of the Year party with
Kobe Bryant I'm so hot yo why am I
always high around he's athletes out
that's why I can't get them to perform
an all-star weekend ain't like every
time while they in the picture with
somebody ba he's high [ __ ] look at my
heart where are my eyes where are they
rolled back north goddamn younger me
what did you know what [ __ ] so I know
that the the cloud smoke was heavy
they're probably like my sponsors [ __ ]
like drop you off for to say hey man
I'll be right outside to pick you up
i cold me all right kobe high-beam all
right you ready to move on I was joking
my eyes are just small when cameras are
so this next one is dirty dicks very
aggressive brand name not that there's
anything wrong with that guy might never
mind it's 2017 almost the ditch don't
meet the one I'm crushing crazy night oh
that was good but I can't just by
default there's gotta be like don't I
the dicks don't be one of them
[Laughter]
so at first we feast were fascinated
with celebrity Yelpers and in 2013 you
had a great run reviewing restaurants
for the people one of my favorites a
spot the 75 of which you said the broth
is so good I wish I could put it in a 32
ounce Gatorade bottle and go ball
somewhere
have you considered getting back into
the Yelp game because I think the people
miss you um I can't leave y'all belong
the game needs me bro I'm oblem I'll
make my return soon but it's gonna be a
nice way I need some free food man from
some of you [ __ ] man
[ __ ] well do you still love mr. Chow
as much as he did when he gave it a
glowing five star review on August 28th
2013 I do but it has been featured in it
like way too many rap songs and I gotta
kind of like relinquish some of my love
for that was my follow-up why do rappers
love mr. Chow so much cuz your rhymes
with a lot of [ __ ] no Charles now kow
how loud xanax they can what they gonna
fit that more [ __ ] there some wig do
you travel around with your own batch of
mumbo sauce because I got that
impression from reading your review of
AJ bombers and Milwaukee do you travel
with your own sauce we did it's it gets
a little bit you know hectic sometimes
tough to get three like to go do my bags
and all of that stuff like ironic like a
weirdo or nothing like that keep
traveling around with [ __ ] hot sauce
and mumbles oh I just use it it's a
delicacy now I just when I'm back home I
give my reopening you know I let it go
there you go you're ready to move on
wale yes alright so this next one is the
zombie apocalypse it's starting to crank
things that sounds healthy
your crews right there zombie no problem
huh
oh that's what I'm not maybe maybe not
you know what I mean like your
disposition drives the edit not the
other way around you know I don't know
what that means but it sounds good like
we wouldn't we wouldn't bomb drop you
unless you're a bomb drop so if you're
just chilling oh sorry I don't do my
research like that I'd kind of skim do
it because I don't think nobody's my
music blip it's all good
well you can say that if you want but I
actually want to talk about your music
right now that well you're good man yo
cop you better pay
man pea yeah somebody's bottle right now
dublicate [ __ ] no [ __ ] [ __ ] my own
little wallet yeah go I like so when it
comes to sports references in hip hop I
feel like it's you Action Bronson riff
raff you guys are just light years ahead
of the rest as we've talked about with
your explaining that gram segment you're
a huge sports fan so with that in mind I
want to bounce some of the most classic
male sports bars off of you and then I'm
hoping you can just decode it for me
genius styles that sound good so this
first one's like a little bit of a
mouthful so if you know where it's going
you can take it from me if you want but
it's the chopper body like Hornswoggle
can't see you shot him like Sin Cara
roll up that [ __ ] loud it ain't mine if
that [ __ ] not ladies hate when I Rick
Rude but they in love with that reusing
make me sound like I'm in court like
[ __ ] I'm like very soap operas body
just what now that's just a whole lot of
wrestling [ __ ] and probably they won't
fool less than God give that but that's
what I like because you're hitting four
different wrestlers quickly like that
well it used to be that's what it is the
way I rap I like to I enjoy right but I
like to listen to old jay-z and still
find [ __ ] that was what hip-hop worth to
me personally but it's split looking a
whole lot of different things now that I
also appreciate but as far as what I
doing what I like to do that's that word
play what about this one here I'm
talking Reggie Bush matter of fact ask
Cameron Newton matter of fact go ask
their schools how many jerseys they was
moving yeah so that one that's what
varsity blues and I won his home now
because it's like um some dudes was like
there was up both in scandals in college
you know came likes total computers I'm
like that made the school a gazillion
dollars like he owns an okay I'm saying
this right they're still computers of
[ __ ] but maybe you gotta cut them enough
so that he can buy you can buy his own
[ __ ] computers right where are you
stupid computers you just do for 7,000
yards money you're like that's crazy to
me and they took his Hodgman away bro
like whatever the hell that what
happened didn't take away from the fact
that he was one of the
play the hotel I got one more for you
while a turn it on ESPN you see they got
it in for me and they won't stop until
they got my legacy and infamy that's off
the eye of the tiger you know that was
oh well a lot of weed ago now that with
the Ida Tigers I'm literally I literally
wrote that today the Tiger Woods scandal
hit the fan and I was just writing it as
if I was him and I'm saying the whole
song after I go back and listen to it
it's literally like me going through
everything that happened like as if I
was talking words that day that's when
it was fun to be creative and [ __ ] like
that I used to really like enjoy try and
do new things that she liked that but um
that's it that's that whole song is just
as if I was talking with some
perspective yes there you go well there
you go
you ready to move on alright so this
next one is to bomb beyond insanity have
a caution right
[Music]
shit's getting real nice good taste
tastes good respect
so wale and complex will forever be
linked
thanks to that fateful day and I'm
Johnny 13 when you called the office my
lawyer told me I can't speak one sold us
to get the security ready and threatened
to start knocking people out for leaving
you off the best albums list you might
not remember but I remember I don't
recall officer when you think back on
all those wale moments you don't have to
include that one I wonder which one was
the most fun for you in the time and
then the one that just wasn't worth the
fight you mean that won't go away like
the one that five years later still has
legs is that what you're getting out
chicken uh-huh and you bring it up I
mean obviously I don't know to talk
about so I don't do that anymore I'm a
changed man
whose opinion do you respect more
Anthony Fantana or DJ academics yeah I
can do with Nick we're not gonna slow
cop down this is like a joint like this
is like the all-madden version of media
like get to the end there John is like
ten bouncers with the ill questions um I
just don't think both of these
[ __ ] got like some passionate
like internet fans that just won't like
them doesn't find my address it just
mail me [ __ ] you right yo the fact that
you put both of their names together and
put a question like that at the very end
when my concentration is lapse you know
what I would have done wildly if you
just would have gone with the first
thing if you just have gone with the
first thing I would have let it chill
but then it was the very like I don't
remember that done that I was like
alright well no
kuk-ja yeah he's going in for the kill
um no I just think that the fact that
you put both of their names together
says more about you and your opinion of
them than it does about me so we'll
leave it at that and I mean that so you
guys have to have a h HR meeting with
academics and you got to talk about it
because there's obviously something
going on does he make more than you I
[ __ ] bet he does I [ __ ] bet he
does and yeah we've asked him I know
girl Mac Joe Budden does I don't take oh
sure
Joe you didn't I didn't mean that she
giving me a flush garden spray and I had
nothing to do with it
I didn't drive him let me out though
shoot nothing buddy done she was strange
man his questions are good though and I
do believe that you care about the
culture I do believe it I'm sure I'm not
being sarcastic I think you really care
about the culture some people are in it
for personal gain if I was in this for
personal gain I'd probably be very rich
and I probably have like a standing
doing this interview for me that's how I
retired but I really care and I think my
passion for the ship often gives me in
trouble because when you speak from the
heart man that [ __ ] don't have
no filter right just got a filter you
don't see this kind of filter the heart
will you speak
[ __ ] it though who cares we run the
place now obviously that's how you gonna
lose me indoors from either okay that's
all all right you ready to move on Wally
all right so this next one is Blair's
Megadeth sauce with liquid rage good
school sounds look bathroom
so shortly after this you're gonna do a
panel about the sneaker of the year side
note I'm not sure that hot ones is the
best pre panel activity but for the
layperson who doesn't know a Flyknit
from a boost how would you describe
sneaker culture I don't know first we
feast I checked that [ __ ] for what
burger is the best in my city
more than I check any website just
sneakers these days thank you the
[ __ ] sneaky game has been bastardized
and if you know you know you know pink
box xsb silver boxes and all that go
that was a great area it's fun while it
lasted now these [ __ ] he's
taking a mother's credit card and
reselling [ __ ] box and all that [ __ ] to
buy sneakers it's crazy I don't know
so we wants we can talk about burgers
next time because you know it's
important to talk about the things that
are Roedean sneaker culture too you know
what I mean if you have those kinds of
observations I think that you should
talk about those things yeah I mean IIIi
really just like what I like man and I
feel like when I was coming up it was an
earth I hate bees for room and it was
kind of like look down on the bar a
little bit now that you celebrating like
who got the most who could put the most
maybe walk around with one easy on this
junk one off-white Joe
fear God draws the supreme mouthpiece
everything like it's just [ __ ] you can
pile up on so it's a little different
though but my perspective is somebody
that just enjoys sneakers like I wear my
[ __ ]
alright wale so this is the last dab
it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
and today wale it is a very special day
because a hundred people in the audience
are going to be doing the last dab the
job [ __ ] sound wavers they did
sign waivers they did sign waivers
legally we're in the clear I'm not
worried about it we are not gonna get
sued off the
whatever happens is on you brave souls
this is the first ever group last dab in
world history it is such a special day
this feels like Jonestown all over again
who's in who the [ __ ] is in man right
here in the front I do all right okay
well they usually I say you don't have
to if you don't want to but given the
circumstances that's gonna be a tough
sell for you today oh I gotta do it too
like that that was mine if you want I'd
get yours
I look at you doing so great man well
without without spazzing out or not I
don't know if it's like the audience
this is you know it brings the audience
is making them more difficult
I could feel people looking at me you
think yeah you're not so sure anxiety
man that [ __ ] is real man [ __ ] is
[ __ ] real as hell
toast toast Cheers wale what a run it's
been all right everybody bottoms up for
play just clean it wings dancin atop the
mountain look at this legend Oh Maisie
oh my legacy Jesus God
[ __ ] guy
alright I'll keep this one brief wale
because I have a feeling there's gonna
be a stampede towards the water cooler
any second but you're a guy who's toured
the world stacking platinum plaques and
gold along the way you've performed on
stages all over the place but I have to
imagine that this is a unique experience
having the last dab with a hundred total
strangers so we'll get you out on this
because I know that we've put you
through a lot was this experience more
painful or less painful than everyday
struggle you know when I do everyday
struggle I was like man I gotta party
cuz I'm not irritated but everybody
thinks I'm Earth Day so I learned to be
like alright I'm just gonna laugh at
everything now cuz y'all keep thinking a
man what I gotta do to prove I'm not may
eat chicken in front of y'all that's
racist that is racist why can't I be
eating something else I'm vegan
I want to eat this [ __ ] well then you
should have put it in the rider ahead of
time because we're very accommodating
wale look at you you made it through
beanie and all to everybody in the crowd
let's hear it for wale and then give
yourselves a round of applause cuz this
is cool as [ __ ] this is a dream come
true never thought I'd see something
like this let me be a douche for a
second
hey Cho chikun lunch no la HelloWorld
Sean Evans comin at you to say thank you
for watching if you liked what you saw
please subscribe
we're hovering around the three
thousandth ranked youtube channel in the
world it has been a childhood dream of
mine to be somewhere in the mid twos
we're so close help make an adult bald
man's dreams come true please please
please
jk jk no pressure but if you do
subscribe I appreciate it